this prison security is carried out by
venezuela's national guard
a military unit we've not seen this at a
prison before
we've been stopped from entering here
for days the prison service granted sky
news unprecedented access to its prison
system
but the local authorities insist no
access will be granted here
despite orders from on high
eventually they said they'd change their
minds and would let us in
very soon it became clear to us it
wasn't their decision to make
here it is the prisoners who are in
charge
this is like no prison i've ever seen
before it's more like a town surrounded
by a wall
the prisoners watch on as we walk
through the corridors surrounded by
police
it feels like a poor village they've run
down cafes fast food takeaways
but it's all completely dilapidated
there are no lights in the darkened
accommodation areas
the prisoners hang out in the corridors
and we're told it's a no-go
area for us the prisoners won't allow it
we have 30 minutes and no questions
we've been told about the deal between
the prison guards and the prisoners is
that they basically leave each other
alone then everything stays cool
the prisoners misbehave then the water
the electricity and the food and family
visits go
but if the prisoners get angrier and
angrier then way
of fighting back is to set the prison on
fire
so there's a really tense truce the
whole time
we're joined throughout by a group of
men the man
with the bright yellow trainers we're
told is the prison boss he runs
everything
he and his own guards are all carrying
weapons they're tucked into their shores
the boss takes a dollar a week from the
inmates
there are five and a half thousand
prisoners here
the boss is clearing 5 500 us dollars
every week
inside they have weapons alcohol drugs
and women
this is a prison out of control
venezuela's prison infrastructure and
its legal system are crumbling
and this prison is falling apart
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how the government wants its
prisons to look and they want them to be
called
education centers across the country
inmates are forced onto parade grounds
where they cite revolutionary slogans of
support
for hugo chavez the former president
it's certainly a form of brainwashing
but these prisons
are ruthlessly controlled as well
inmates spend long periods of time
locked up on their prison wings
it did look clean and orderly but
prisoners whispered to us
that it had been cleaned up for our
arrival
they said the prison regime was brutal
and that they were starving
hardly fed at all
showing me her new surveillance system
donated by china
the prison minister said she was proud
of her reforms
as we watched families visiting the
prison wait for the food they bring to
the inmates to be checked
it's clear to us that this is a system
for show not one that functions properly
without this food the prisoners starve
to death
in a country where ordinary people are
starving and live in poverty
where hospitals have no medicine and
virtually nothing works
the prison reforms and the prisons we
were shown
either illustrated government with an
odd perverse set of priorities
or it's another revolutionary myth
mr ramsey sky news valencia venezuela